l'enjeu des trois mois qui viennent
merci la parole et à monsieur daniel
fasquelle
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame ségolène royal
ministre de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie
madame la ministre dans la réponse que
vous avez apporté hier à la question de
mon collègue marc laffineur
vous avez rappelé je cite la compétence
et l'expertisé des chasseurs qui
connaissent parfaitement bien la nature
ce sont vos mots quel décalage pourtant
entre ces belles paroles et la réalité
je ne reviendrai pas sur les nominations
des anti chasse à qui vous avez fait la
part belle au sein d' agence française
pour la biodiversité pour vous interrogé
plus tôt sur votre attitude concernant
les dates de la chasse au gibier d'eau
nous sommes nombreux à vous avoir
interpellé depuis plus de deux ans sur
ce sujet sur tous les bancs d'ailleurs
de l'assemblée plus personne ne conteste
en effet que les oies sont très
abondantes est à l'origine de nombreux
dégâts dans plusieurs pays européens
sous la pression des parlementaires et
des chasseurs vous avez trouvé une
solution provisoire en 2015 et en 2016
vous avez demandé aux services de
l'office national de la chasse et de la
faune sauvage et la gendarmerie de ne
pas sanctionner les chasseurs entre le
1er et le 10 février un braconnage
légale en quelque sorte
alors que la fin du mois de janvier
approche des trois questions à vous
poser 1 alors que d'autres pays comme la
hollande ont obtenu une dérogation pour
la régulation des oies qu'avez-vous fait
concrètement depuis trois ans pour que
la france et ses chasseurs au tiennent
les mêmes avantages
à défaut d'une solution durable
allez-vous de nouveau autorisé la chasse
au gibier d'eau en février que vous
l'avez fait en 2015 et en 2016
même si cette solution est juridiquement
très fragile enfin madame la ministre
vous voulez vous vraiment aider les
chasseurs ou êtes-vous déjà tellement
absorbé par votre soutient emmanuel
macron ne vous n'avez plus le temps nous
occuper d'eux
la parole est à madame ségolène royal
ministre de l'environnement de l'énergie
de la mer
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
le député les chasseurs constituent des
partenaires très important du ministère
de l'environnement
et comme vous le savez que ce soit dans
mes responsabilités d'élu local et
régional au d'élus nationale j'ai
toujours entretenu d'excellentes
relations avec les chasseurs et
notamment parce que c'est un loisir en
milieu rural qui doit être respecté et
valorisé
maintenant il a été proposé aux
chasseurs d'entrer dans l' agence
française pour la biodiversité les
chasseurs ont refusé donc ce refus a été
respectée mais je souhaite qu'il y ait
des partenariats qui se nouent dans les
départements je voudrais vous dire deux
choses la première c'est que je viens
d'écrire à tous les préfets de tous les
départements pour trouver cinq
départements qui acceptent de lancer
l'expérimentation de rapprochement de la
police de la chasse et de la police de
l'eau sur les territoires parce que
c'est comme ça que nous travaillerons
intelligemment ensemble et ses
départements exemplaires seront
accompagnés financièrement pour réaliser
des opérations et des actions
opérationnelles en direction de la
nature
ça c'est le premier point le second ce
qui concerne les oies cendrées
j'ai regardé très attentivement parce
que comme vous je me suis étonné de la
différence de réglementation d'un pays à
l'autre de l'europe
j'ai donc puisqu'on demande et
concrètement écrit à l'ensemble de mes
homologues démunis chargé de l'achat sur
l'ensemble des territoires concernés par
les par les oies par le gibier d'eau en
particulier par les oies cendrées pour
que nous puissions ensemble mettre en
place une réglementation commune
en l'état actuel des choses je vous
conseillerais pas de me demander à
nouvel arrêté je n'ai pas la base
juridique pour le faire cet arrêté
serait immédiatement annulée par le
conseil d'état
en revanche ce que je puis vous dire et
le député plisson d'ailleurs m'a
également saisi en ce sens c'est que je
vais renouveler le dispositif de bon
sens que j'avais trouvé l'année dernière
et l'année d'avant et par conséquent il
n'y aura pas de verbalisation jusqu'au
10 février